check this out from daily mail waukesha
massacre suspect daryl brooks was
convicted for threatening to bomb nugget
casino in nevada and is still wanted
after failing to appear in court they
charged this guy in 2007 for calling in
a bomb threat to the to the nugget
casino he was put on probation after
being convicted of conspiring to disturb
the piece of gross misdemeanor
and was banned from the casino his rap
sheet also includes a conviction for
let's just say he was trafficking minors
and i believe he had a child with the
minor i mean this guy is is you know
we'll try to keep it family friendly
here not a good not a good guy not good
at all but based on this as well as
other information that's come out what
andy noe reported and then i used in my
reporting which really triggered the
media they were so angry oh no don't
tell everybody this guy supports black
lives matter and that he's promoted
black nationalism and that he's
threatened to harm white people because
that's the truth and so if you look at
this and you look at jack posobic you
put out the court police report
this car
was slowly creeping up towards the
parade it was not a pursuit he was not
fleeing anything and he was going slow
enough that one of the officers was able
to walk up to the car bang on the hood
walk over bang on the door and then the
car speeds through
choosing to go down this path
it was not it was not pursued this was
an intentional act he's been so uh let
me put this way
they've charged to the guy with
intentional homicide
witnesses said he was swerving into
people the police said he was slowly
moving up and they banged the car
telling him to stop he's posted about
how he's wanted to kill white people he
supported black nationalism and black
lives matter
but the media says it was an accident
the media is downplaying this they're
criticizing me and andy no and many
others who are pointing these things out
what do you call it if a guy goes online
threatens harm against white people
and then gets in an suv
drives up to a parade route runs over a
bunch of white people
well my answer i always got the answer
you just that's just a traffic accident
buddy
you're connecting too many dots over
there what do you even think you're
doing that's not the narrative that's
not what the police officers told us it
was an suv so this is what you get if
you have a guy who goes on social media
and says he wants to harm white people
and then he runs through a parade route
directly through it swerving into people
what you get
is an suv involved in an accident right
well so here's here's what
and you can go see go to waukesha county
dot gov you can see the entire thing
i've got it written up as detective
casey uh did officer berlin you know
they come up and they talk about this
where they say it was driving so slow
that they were able to walk up to it
knock on the hood then he brushes them
aside but he's still going slow
then they're able to knock on the window
right and say stop you can't go in there
that's a parade route at that point he
turns and drives so if you go look at
the videos if you freeze it you can
actually see that his um his hood is
already damaged right before he gets
there that's because he had to drive
through barricades to get onto the
parade route so he combined that with
this video
that just uh some add-on went and filmed
himself driving down that road and then
they time it up with the videos and they
realize that you would have to be
driving slow and then speed up but
here's the key here's the key point of
that
and i talk to people locally from the
the myth and form guys you know those
guys yeah they're in milwaukee so
they're telling me they said jack
waukesha it's you know it's not like
some town where you can get stuck
there's a million ways in and out
there's plenty of routes you know it's
ridiculous to even think that you would
somehow be you know accidentally trapped
on a parade route so as the car's
driving you can see this in the dash cam
video
that this guy filmed you have to make a
hard right turn
into where the parade route was so it's
that hard right turn where he would have
to smash through the barricades and then
speed up to be able to go through that
is intent how far away did uh brooks
live
oh he he lived in milwaukee that's like
25 minutes away so did he he came
apparently he came from a domestic
they're saying there are no no they said
there was an altercation nearby i think
it's totally unrelated it's weird so
they're they it was a boat ramp believe
it or not of all things right so there's
a boat ramp that's what you hear on the
police scanner that uh there's this
altercation and there's something about
hey that's actually why the first police
officer went over let's see i can pull
this up
that he went over at approximately 4 35
p.m detective casey heard via waukesha
police radio that a reserve officer was
informed by a citizen that two people
were fighting in the area of a of white
rock school squads were sent to that
area to further investigate a few
minutes later detective casey hear into
the horn honking from an area north of
his location and that's where he goes in
and sees him uh
go essentially going into the parade
route i'm just wondering you know this
guy lives so far away why was he out
there right you know i think it's
obvious
i think anybody who looks at the story
says
in the absence of evidence the solution
with the least amount of assumptions
tends to be correct and that looks like
a terror attack again you know a racial
uh racial and political terror attack
based on what this guy had said and
believed and
it's possible it wasn't to be completely
honest but that's the absence of
evidence what we have here is it was an
intentional act it was deliberate and we
can see his motivations uh we can see
some of his inclinations on social media
that doesn't mean i'll correct does it
mean motivations
but
i think you know when we're dealing with
crimes and stuff it is reasonable for a
person to try and figure out what motive
may have been
at this point it is reasonable to assume
this was a terror attack for racial and
political reasons before real quick we
had just two days before this the
written house verdict we had an activist
reported on the 20th this was one day
an activist it was reported had said
that this country is a tinderbox and one
more you know one more
match or whatever and it's going to go
up we had tons of people on the left we
had that democrat in illinois saying
it's karma we had activists on twitter
saying they wanted revenge saying go you
know to to do bad things
and then come sunday
a guy who's made posts about harming
white people goes and does a bad thing
it's absurd to me
do not start with that hypothesis it's
crazy how like if someone
the way the way murder can can happen
and how people will respond differently
like if that guy had been face to face
with each of those individuals looking
in their eyes and using a knife to kill
them each one after the other if this
would be another realm then being behind
the icy cold steel of a car where they
can't see your face it's like a drone
dropping a drone bomb as opposed to
being the one there doing the killing i
mean but he's like i understand that i
understand the drone argument but they'd
be stringing them up if you but actually
like a knife killer and had had blood
all over his body and stuff there's
there are two lines here that i was just
about to read and one of them speaks to
exactly what you're talking about
because it says
officer buterin observed the driver
looking straight ahead directly at him
and it appeared he had no emotion on his
face as the vehicle passed his location
he continually yelled for the vehicle to
stop skip ahead a little bit they shot
at him right he they did shoot at him he
hurt the vehicle then appeared so okay
so they knew he was he was
he was preparing to attack these people
and they tried to use deadly force to
stop it at that point obviously they
perceived him as an eminent deadly
threat that's why they fired the shots
officer buterin heard tires squeal as
the vehicle appeared to rapidly
accelerate the vehicle took an abrupt
left turn into the crowd of parade
participants at this point it was clear
that this was an intentional act to
strike and hurt as many people as
possible
and so uh i love this if we if we
operate on what the police said they
said they ruled out terror
then i can only say
impulse i mean it's not passion passion
you know
you maybe argue passion but was he mad
about was he like he was driving up and
he saw some karen yelling and he was
like oh now i'm really angry and in this
passionate moment there was no great
passion so it was just likely it would
only matter anyway if the passion was
aroused by the people he uses
right so that's clearly not the case so
maybe drugs
i would love to see uh a toxicology
report here oh it would be off the
charts would be my expectation i mean
that ring video and the mug shot that's
come out i mean this does not seem like
a guy who's operating is right he'll
have everything on that graph and that
may be why the police said it's not
terror because it turns out the guys
just you know whacked out of his mind
and was just slamming the gas thinking
he was running over gummy bears or
something you know he's like trip you
know tripping and crazy so my issue is i
would love to believe this guy was just
on drugs i don't want to live in a world
it certainly wouldn't be the first
terrorist attack that was committed by
someone on drugs no for sure for sure
i'm just saying
if someone was on drugs we can then
argue oh okay so so
there's evidence to suggest maybe it
wasn't terror just a drug addict doing
something crazy there's still i think
it's still a fair assumption that this
guy was politically motivated in what he
did i'm just saying right now there is
no evidence of drugs the only thing we
have is this guy's political statements
about wanting to hurt white people which
you know something about banging heads
or something and then getting a car and
doing this plus the timing plus the
political nature of what's been going on
and so i lean towards not definitively
but i think it's a fair assumption it
was terror if they come out the
toxicology report and say he was on
drugs it would shift more towards the
middle again and i'd say it's still you
know likely it could be terror but it
could also be the guy was whacked out of
his mind so here's my thing too and you
know i had kind of already been thinking
this with um
some of those social media posts that
you and andy were highlighting i went
through a ton of them myself before the
thing got taken down andy andy was
highlighting yeah i was just citing
reporting right right right and so and
now i think new york post has put it up
daily mail's put it up
but specifically now of course you know
the the anti-white post the fbi is not
tracking that they're just not yeah but
the anti-police posts that he add up the
post about killing police officers
that's something that definitely would
he had a post about killing cops right
wow talked about you know called them
pigs and this type of thing uh back in
2020 and that's definitely something
that would have put him on the radar so
one of the things that i
was thinking about reading this was and
of course in all of these cases we you
know it seems that we always come up to
an extent where
they were known to the fbi subject was
known to fbi right don't we always do we
always hear about this and so i was
wondering based on those posts i'm like
yeah he's probably in a file somewhere
because that would have pinged the
algorithm but then we hear this thing
about the casino
and that he threatened to bomb a casino
that's like okay
fbi has definitely got a file on this
they know him 100 well in fairness i'm
also known to the fbi i teach at the
academy there
yeah but i mean i've i've been through
some fbi training myself something i
find interesting about this whole thing
is is we have the story itself right why
did they do this was it intentional were
there drugs kind of the core story but
then there's also the meta-story like
why are all these people instantly
coming to his defense trying to explain
away what happened
or just cover up
he was chased by someone with a knife or
there was a gunfighter there was some
innocent explanation for this it wasn't
actually a an act of malice that did
this thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time